the Lone Star State stepping up its push
for enhanced border security planning to
deploy armored military vehicles to 10
locations along the border this comes
days after Governor Greg Abbott invoked
The Invasion Clause of his State's
Constitution but why now let's ask
former acting DHS deputy secretary Ken
cuccinelli Ken great to see you this
morning let's start with let's start
with the news from earlier this week I'm
going to read a bit from Governor
Abbott's letter and let me get your
reaction to what he had to say at that
time and then we'll get to his follow-up
actions the letter said the following to
President Biden your silence in the face
of a repeated pleas are deafening your
refusal to even visit the border to look
firsthand the chaos you have caused his
damning your open border policies which
have catalyzed an unprecedented crisis
of illegal immigration are the sole
cause of Texas having to invoke our
constitutional authority to defend
ourselves this letter went on to say Ken
as you and I both have noticed that
Texas will Deport illegal immigrants
to the Border tell me your reaction
well to the border is not deporting and
understand Deport is an immigration word
just to be clear this isn't immigration
law Texas has the authority under the
Constitution to protect itself its
sovereignty and its borders when it is
invaded well Governor Abbott has
acknowledged that Texas is being invaded
he's acknowledged the Constitution gives
them the ability to protect themselves
and this is a war power that's awkward
wording but that's what the founders put
in the Constitution and the key isn't
force not tanks and planes the key is
being able to stop people and turn them
around and put them back into Mexico but
he said to the border and the Border in
Texas is the middle of the Rio Grande
and nobody is going to drop people in
the middle of the river they have to
cross the river put them back into
Mexico and do it at scale so they
actually slow the flow of people
crossing their border illegally or this
will be as meaning English as 18 months
of operation Lone Star you look back at
operation Lone Star he's been doing it
for 18 months they've spent four billion
dollars and the flow of illegal entrance
has gone up not down up so this is the
one step he clearly acknowledges he has
the Constitutional Authority but he's
not doing the one thing that will slow
the flow which is to remove illegal
immigrants across back to the Mexican
side of the border so your argument Ken
is while he is using the correct wording
in declaring an invasion he is not
executing the actions that that power
would imbue the state of Texas does
anything and this is the question I
wanted to follow up secondarily with you
does anything since that announcement
convince you because we just mentioned
he's going to deploy these armored
trucks to the border is there anything
since the Declaration of invasion that
suggests well his actions will actually
live up to hopefully your expectations
and the power of declaring invasion
no and the word I get sort of back
channel from the DPS which is their
State Police is that nothing has changed
this is another press effort another
photo op by Governor Abbott and that
comes from people who are determined not
to do it the leadership of DPS Steve
McCraw in particular does not want to do
this as long as Steve McCraw is there
Greg Abbott is probably not going to
actually move you know why that is why
do Texas DPS not want this part he just
vehemently opposes it and we learned in
the Trump Administration when people on
your own team oppose the policy guess
what it finds a way not to work right so
when we hope Governor Abbott becomes
serious about this Texas could make a
big dent in the flow from Mexico but so
far he hasn't done that well Ken I
always appreciate your perspective in
highlighting what it's important to
understand what people's words mean and
what that then means for our policy and
our execution and our actions and I
appreciate you focusing on that this
morning morning Ken we've I've paid
attention to what you've had to say
throughout the weekend we appreciate it
you will all right I'm Steve Ducey I'm
Brian Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley Earhart
and click here to subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis